is a totally autonomous solar powered
infrastructure independent security
tower so by placing these towers every
few miles you can end up with a nearly
perfect picture of everything that's
going on in a really large area and then
that data is very easy for an operator
to read these are being used right now
by the dod by department of homeland
security along military bases the border
and a lot of other critical
infrastructure
andrew's future success relies largely
on the military's continued concern that
the u.s could lose to china in an arms
race based on artificial intelligence
our technology is far behind the
consumer area in many places and we're
also far behind our adversaries in a lot
of places people should be more worried
than they are about falling behind
because it's not something that's going
to happen someday it's already happened
critics say technologists like lucky
have an ethical duty to stay out of the
weapons business but neither the
military nor anderle's investors share
their concerns the company recently
raised a 120 million dollar investment
round valuing it at about one billion
dollars
i'm scarlet foo and this is bloomberg
quick take gallane maxwell's sex
trafficking trial began this week in new
york and at the end of day two we heard
from one of jeffrey epstein's female
victims as well as his former pilot
gillian maxwell as you know is charged
with recruiting underage girls for
epstein and participating in some of his
abuse of the girls i want to bring in
now bloomberg news legal team editor and
team leader katyak porzikanziki who has
been following this trial from the very
beginning when they began selecting the
jury katya thanks so much for for
speaking with us um i want to take a
step back for a moment here and and just
talk to you about
the framing of this trial because
opening arguments were yesterday that's
done witnesses are now testifying
what's the narrative that the
prosecution has laid out and what's the
narrative that the defense has laid out
absolutely so the prosecutors um are
going to be calling uh four
um alleged victims who are going to
paint the picture of
gillane maxwell's role in their abuse
that took over um that that was from
decades ago um but that you know they
say have you know permanently altered
their lives um and they are going to um
basically talk about how she helped in
in bringing and sourcing girls for uh
jeffrey epstein and grooming them for
abuse which which take took many
different forms uh for for the different
the different uh women who were then
girls um you know whether it was paying
for their school or or um being some
sort of a role model or social sort of
source of support if they had sometimes
um you know like volatile lives uh it
was all part of a grooming process and
that's what uh what they are um alleging
and there are six counts against her um
and
uh the steepest one would carry a
sentence of 40 years and she's found
guilty of that okay gotcha so that's the
prosecution's version or the story that
they're going to tell
with the help of these four female
victims as witnesses how's the defense
countering this what is the defense
saying about what elaine maxwell did or
didn't do
so the defense um has went right for it
uh yesterday in their opening statement
basically saying that
what we're going to hear is is
basically memories that are are wrong um
and uh and that delane uh didn't have
that uh didn't have that role that she
is a scapegoat for jeffrey epstein
um
that the that basically because jeffrey
epstein has committed suicide there's no
one else to blame and so they're going
after elaine maxwell who
was a ex-girlfriend of his and a
property manager of his and um and
basically she's as the as the attorney
for for maxwell said yesterday she's
filling an empty seat
um
so which is which is an interesting
argument also because you know she is a
woman and she's the first woman to go to
trial in the metoo era um or the in the
post of the 22 era so uh it's it's an
interesting um
question for for uh for a juror to face
um given that mostly it's men in this
position yeah i think that's a really
important point and it's notable here
that the defendant is a woman the
prosecutor is a woman uh the defendant's
lead lawyer
is a woman as well and you have these
four women who will be called up as
witnesses there are victims they're all
women and the judge is a woman as well
we can get to that in a moment here but
um i want to talk about what happened
today on day two of the trial because uh
the former pilot of jeffrey epstein his
former
private jet pilot uh testified today and
i know a lot's gonna be made of the fact
that he name-checked a whole bunch of
celebrities like chris tucker the
comedian kevin spacey the actor
bill clinton and donald trump the former
presidents all that's interesting and
i'm sure it's going to make all the
different tabloids but what did we
actually learn from this former pilot
what did we learn from his testimony
so
um the pilot worked for jeffrey epstein
for almost 30 years
piloting him around and
saw many many people entered the jets um
over the course of that time and
basically you know
he's testified over the course of two
days and this on the first day he was
basically saying well you know this is
uh it's easier to fly private um a lot
less hassle so a lot of people like to
fly private so people would hitch rides
on jeffrey epstein's jets um and then
you know that's kind of what sets up him
seeing a lot of these famous people um
and you know
again these names that have been dropped
are not new they've been released you
know in depositions over the years um
but
the inter the key point of his presence
on the stand
was to basically say that he saw with
his own eyes one of the victims on that
jet um and that is uh
jane is her pseudonym um the women are
going by pseudonyms um and and
saw her uh when he
she was given like a tour of the jet and
he noticed her um she had bright blue
eyes she appeared mature to his to his
uh knowledge there were he never saw
women under the age of what he expected
with or thought was 20 on on board um
but that woman prosecutors say had been
groomed but and actually abused by
allegedly by jeffrey epstein and delaney
maxwell starting from the age of 14
where they approached her um
at her art camp
um and interlochen
and uh and indeed the
the pilot also did confirm that he flew
the jet at one point to um the nearest
airport to interlock in uh to pick up
luggage
but it's
so there are there are pieces there that
um are kind of painting a picture
uh but the the cro on cross exam they
they
basically asked them you know like what
did you see did you see any wrongdoing
and um
and he said that he never saw any
females who appeared to be under the age
of 20 during the three decades that he
piloted the planes nor any illegal
activity aboard when he'd leave the
cockpit to use the restroom so um
so it's it's but it's a visual you know
confirmation that that that victim was
there
under epstein's watch um and then the
the uh the government gave um a list of
birth certificates um and flight records
to the jury uh presumably to show them
the age of that witness um to say yeah
she was underage okay so it's to place
the fact that the victim was on the jet
even though the pilot himself said that
uh the door between the cockpit and the
rest of the private jet was always
closed so he didn't actually see
anything even if there was something to
see or even if there wasn't anything to
see
um you had mentioned jeffrey epstein
killed himself while he was in prison he
was awaiting trial at the time so he
never really had to face the music here
and so gelane maxwell's attorneys have
argued that she's kind of a convenient
stand-in a scapegoat because he's not
able to um be accountable held
accountable for what uh is is being
alleged of him so how much does his
shadow loom over this trial i mean are
people saying his name constantly i
assume they are but how much
deliberation is there when it comes to
him
versus delane maxwell is it really a
trial about him or is it really about
her
i mean his shadow looms large i mean in
so much of the testimony today including
right now we have um jane that minor
victim she she's testifying as well
today um and has been for the last
couple hours and
it's a lot about the abuse that he that
that he committed and
um it's heavy i mean it's really dark uh
the allegations that she that she makes
especially given how young she was um
and the role that he played in kind of
giving her
uh an apartment um and and giving her
schooling um and it's all part of the
grooming process um
uh and that's that's where maxwell comes
in and she did describe that maxwell um
was present when he would abuse her um
to give her a sense of oh this is fine
this is normal i'm right here
and that's you know so epstein's
role in the crimes is massive but but it
sets the stage to ask well what was
maxwell's role in those crimes and
that's what the point of the trial is
so she has been um detained and she's
been in prison for months now um we've
we're seeing her in court
what do the reporters who are at the
courthouse every day you are editing
their stories you're constantly in
communication with them what are they
saying about how gillane maxwell
presents what is she like what's her
body language like during during these
testimonies
um it seems like she's been pretty
reserved and quiet um at least that's
what uh it's that's what it sounds like
she hugs her attorneys when she gets
into court and when she leaves at the
end
um
and uh
and so but so far there's been
you know
looking at the jury
or
looking at the victims and but not not a
lot to say about her demeanor so far
she's been pretty composed there hasn't
much to say there hasn't been anything
to write about what she's been doing
and i'm sure that's the way that her
defense attorney wants it too
i mentioned earlier how this is it feels
like an all-women trial female judge
female defendant female prosecutor uh
four female witnesses one of whom
already testified today
what do we know about the jury you were
there at the beginning when the
attorneys were picking the juries um
what can you tell us about the jury and
how they are responding to
this uh very female dominated trial
well we have no idea what they're
thinking um but the jury uh is
a fairly
good representation of new yorkers it
sounds like from their bios we were able
to piece together from transcripts um
what they do for a living um you know
what their general demographics are
how exposed they had been to this trial
or to the to the characters before um
which was really interesting because it
kind of made a point like where are you
going to find people that have never
heard of jeffrey epstein exactly
for this trial but they did i mean i
mean they didn't find people that have
never heard of jeffrey epstein but a lot
of them were like oh i flipped the
channel like i saw something but i
flipped the channel you know we've got
home health aides we've got government
workers um like an advertising guy
and in terms of their their gender
makeup we don't have that confirmed yet
um but it's a it's it's it seems like a
pretty uh
balanced representation um
and actually one of the jurors got
excused today because he had a surprise
christmas vacation planned
and so last minute they had to change
out a jury a juror um
which you know everyone was probably
cursing at the sky that this one person
got to leave and enjoy his holidays
i'm kidding exactly especially since
we're only at the beginning of this
trial very quickly as we wrap up here
katya what are you looking for in the
coming days what do you think you guys
will be writing on as kind of the
sidebar to what else is happening day in
and day out through this trial
um i i think
what i'm very interested in is is the
you know just exactly painting the
picture of their of their environment
and who was in there and you know who
the witnesses are like we have no idea
who the witnesses in this trial are
going to be which is really interesting
because sometimes you get a witness list
but in this case it's sealed so it's
actually a surprise like almost every
time um so it'll be really interesting
to see who's coming to speak obviously
we're gonna have the four women in total
speak but then all the women all any any
people that that saw them um
uh we never know you know
it's unlikely that they're going to be
any surprises in terms of name drops but
it could be that there are some
surprises in terms of you know what
those people did or saw
and i and the
um and i think
hopefully i mean we'll probably hear
from more um for more women uh who who
may might not be one of the minor
victims but might be
called to corroborate or to explain a
little bit more or give credibility to
those women so
um it's going to be a really interesting
trial um it's a you know window into a a
very
seedy underbelly of you know manhattan
wealth and florida wealth
and and so i think that's why there's so
much interest in this case uh given that
you know it seemed to have happened
right in front of a lot of people's
faces and a lot of those people are
famous people yeah definitely feels like
it could be something that was um made
up for hbo max or or netflix um if it
weren't for the fact that it's true
katya thank you so much katya
porzikonsky bloomberg news legal team
leader and editor really appreciate you
joining us